[موسيقى]
من مهرجان الابل ينضم الينا اسامه القاسم
وراسن صباح العربيه وضيفه محمد الحربي
المتحدث الرسمي للمهرجان اهلا بك معنا
يعني حذاء الابل ضمن قائمه اليونسكو
للتراث الثقافي عرفنا اكثر على هذا
الارتباط الوجداني بين السعوديه تفضل
اهلا وسهلا سهام تحيه طيبه لك ولجميع
الساده المشاهدين اتواجد اليوم نعم في مقر
مهرجان الملك عبد العزيز الابل والذي
يعتبر اكبر مهرجان للابل في العالم بجوائز
مليونيه تصل الى اكثر 250 مليون ريال هذا
المهرجان الذي يضم العديد من الفعاليات
العديد ايضا من المسابقات التي تقيس جمال
الابل الموجود في هذا المهرجان قبل اسبوع
تقريبا دخل الحذاء الى ضمن التراث العالم
في منظمه اليونسكو كترات السعوديه خليجي
عربي وبتاكيد انه هذا التراث يعتبر ثقافه
كبير جدا ويعبر عن ثقافه المنطقه العربيه
حذاء الابل وتفاصيل كثيره عن انضمامه
لمنظمه اليونسكو عن ايضا تفاصيل مهرجان
الابل الذي يعد اكبر مهرجان في العالم
الذي تواجد به العدد كبير جدا من المزايين
والمتنافسين طوال ايام المهرجان الابل
اليوم تعبر عن ثقافه السعوديين اهتمامهم
الكبير والبالغ جدا باقتناء الابل
والمشاركه بها
بالمنافسات الحديث اكثر شه يكون معي الان
الاستاذ محمد الحربي هو المتحدث الرسمي
لمهرجان الابل ارحب بك ابتداءا معنا في
صباح العربيه حدثني اليوم عن ابرز همم
فعاليات مهرجان الابل والى كم يستمر
المهرجان يا مرحبا صبح عليك صبح على الاخت
سهام وعلى استاذ المشاهدين بالتاكيد احنا
عندما نتحدث عن مهرجان الملك عبد العزيز
نسخه السابعه اليوم نتحدث عن تراكم سنوات
من الخبرات في تنظيم مثل هذه المسابقات
الكبيره سبع سنوات او سبع مواسم لهذا
المهرجان مهرجان
يهتمراتنا بثقافتنا بالموروث ايضا كما قلت
انت هو اكبر مهرجان للابل في العالم واكبر
جوائز تقدم في مسابقه ايضا على مستوى
العالم يصاحب هذا المهرجان العديد من
الفعالياتها بالاضافه الى مثلا العروض
الرسميه للابل او مشاهده العرض الرئيس
للابل امام لجنه التحكيم هناك ايضا العديد
من فعاليات المصاحبه سواء فيما يخص
المنتجات الابل وصناعتها سواء فيما يخص
يعني الاهازيج المصاحبه للابل او قال او
حذاء لبل كما نقول هذا كله مستخدم على ارض
الصياهد بالاضافه الى يعني اكبر سوق يمكن
للمنتجات الشعبيه موجود على شارع الدهنه
شارع اللي عبرنا منه لهذا الموقع بطوله
تقريبا 15 كم يوجد فيها العديد من الخدمات
المقدمه لرواد الصياهد او المحبي الابل
لمشاهده هذه العروض همم يعني العديد من
المنتجات التي تباع في هذا منتجات قد لا
تجدها في موقع اخر اليوم احنا نتكلم عن
حدائق الابل ودخوله في منظمه يونسكو كتراث
عالمي يمتازت به الجزيره العربيه وتحديدا
السعوديه والخليج كيف يتم خلق هذا المجيد
والتواصل بين الراعي الابل والابل ما هي
ايضا اللهجات التي يتحدث بها الراعي وكيف
وصلت الى ان تصبح ثقافه عالميه اليوم
وبالتاكيد يعني
نجاح كبير جدا
لهيئه التراث بالتعاون مع نادي الابل في
نجاح الهباه ضمن التراث اللامادي في
اسبانيول هذه اللغه ما بين مالك الابل
والابل هي لغه جميله رائعه جدا محببه
للناس اا يسمى حذاء الابل القديمه وهو ليس
جديد طبعا متوارث عبر مئات السنين وربما
الف السنين منذ نستانس الانسان الجمل
وهناك لغه تفاهم بين الجمل والانسان
الهوابيل كمان نسميها حنا في اللغه
الدارجه او الهبال او حذاء الابل في الاسم
العربي وهو ضمن طرق الشعر ايضا وضمن يعني
همم الشعر المحبب للناس او للهجيني او هذه
الاشعار التي يتغنى فيها الركبان سواء
السائرون على الابل او للغه لمناداه الابل
تسجيل هذا التراث بالنسبه لنا نجاح كبير
جدا همم يعني تسجيل هذا ضمن التراث اللي
العالم اللي يتعرف العالم على تراثنا
وثقافتنا واصالتنا احنا نتكلم اليوم عن
مهرجان الابل اكبر مهرجان في العالم من
جميع النواحي من جميع الاشياء الموجوده في
هذا المهرجان
اليوم هو بالتاكيد يعتبر مكان لهواه الابل
سواء في التربيه وحتى على مستوى المزادات
والبيع كم تقريبا عدد الناس اللي بداوا
بزياره المهرجان وكم تتوقعون ايضا انه في
نسخته السابعه ان يصل الاعداد الزائرين
حنتوقع ان شاء الله نتجاوز المليون زائر
لهذا المهرجان همم يعني خلال فتره طبعا
فتره فتره المهرجان تعد فتره طويله نسبيا
45 يوم لاقامه المزاين او لتغطيه انواع
الابل في الوانها السته
لسباقات كبيره من ضمنها ايضا اشواط ملكيه
همم
جوائز ضخمه وايضا اشواط تهتم بالبداوه
وبالاصاله وايضا هناك صوت نسائي باسم
الاميره نوره بنت عبد الرحمن تخليدا لهذه
المراه العظيمه وهو شوط خاص بالنساء همم
للتشجيعهم على تملك الابل والاهتمام فيها
يعني والحمد لله كانت الشوط انطلق من
العام الماضي وتم تسميته هذا العام ضمن
الاشواط الملكيه ونتوقع ان شاء الله مزيد
من المشاركات ايضا همم سواء في هذا الشوط
او في الاشواط الاخرى استاذ محمد يحيى انت
متحدث الرسمي لمرجان الابل شكرا لك اذا
سهام احنا نتحدث اليوم عن اكبر مهرجان همم
للابل في العالم يعني المنطقه التي يقع
فيها المرجان هي منطقه
الرماحات اتمنى
110 بالتالي هذه المنطقه مليئه جدا مليئه
جدا بالفعاليات وانتقال لك في الاستديو
شكرا لك